هجوم العمالقه الاعلى تقييما على مستوى
اعمال الانمي يدور حول كفاح البشريه ضد
العمالقه للبقاء على قيد الحياه فكره
بسيطه لكن خلفها عشرات الحكايات والكثير
جدا من المشاعر في الاصل كان من المفترض
ان يكون ايرينجر بطل القصه عملاقا طوال
الوقت لكن هجيمي سياما كاتب المانجا تراجع
عن الفكره اما ميكاسا فهي اول شخصيه قام
بابتكارها خطط الكاتب ايضا ان ينهي
المانجا بنهايه الماساويه حيث تموت كل
الشخصيات لكن التقييمات الايجابيه
والمتابعه الكبيره للعمل دفعته لتغيير
الاحداث بسبب تعلق المعجبين بالابطال قصص
المانجا بدات قبل سبع سنوات تقريبا من عرض
الانمي لاول مره وحاليا يتكلف انتاج
الحلقه الواحده 300 الف دولار واخيرا بعد
نجاح اتاك اون تيتان كان هجيبي ايسياما
اغنى كاتب مانجا عام 2021
وتكسر ثروته اليوم حاجزه الخمسه واربعين
مليون دولار